now we know that uh you know you began
acting at a very young age i believe in
a drama
uh group hometown yeah so was it your
plan all along to
continue as a career as you have done
or did the narnia casting change
everything oh the narnia casting
completely changed everything i mean i
i wasn't even wanting to be um acting as
a child
um and just loved doing
doing it in my own time like as a hobby
you know never thought about it
professionally
um but the whole narnia experience just
gave me this massive
passion for it and now i can't think of
anything else which would
satisfy me more i mean there's
definitely other things that i want to
try i mean i'm
interested in writing and directing but
um yeah
acting will always you know be a
real a real love for me after that
experience
you